let's go to the phones my friends we are
going to hear from the most important
people
to the show which are the people in the
audience we do these calls via Discord
at davidpackman.com
Discord as a reminder you have to
request to speak if you would like to
chat with me very important in order to
be called on your name must be in the
format of name and location or location
and name so people with jokes or
nicknames or you know obvious stuff like
that you won't be called on
so typically the names would be
something like for example Harry from
Columbus Ohio that's the first person to
join us today Harry welcome to the show
what's on your mind today
David can you hear me I can hear you
beautifully
that's Pleasant last time my audio was
well it was at hacked by intify I have
no other way to put it really they
pronounce it now it's pronounced antifa
so
um you said recently you're back in the
gym now I want to just say one thing
please if you said that you run before
you lift just I do and I'm wondering I'm
wondering if you're gonna tell I have
read that it's better to lift first
because then you're at maximum strength
and then do your cardio
absolutely that is
the only tweak I have I hear you're
hitting the weights I won't ask you how
or in what specific way I'll let you get
into that detail when you're ready of
course well I'm ready right now I mean I
don't know what you're hearing uh listen
do you enjoy listen I'm not like some
kind of uh I I'm not Reinventing the
wheel here you know it's like I have
found I I look online and I say okay if
I'm doing a mix of cardio and weights
and in total I want to be doing four
days a week what's the best mix to do
and it's like oh okay on this day do
rowing machine and then do arms and then
the next day you can do legs and then
run or you know whatever it's just like
I kind of just I just try to stay
organized in that way
yeah it's good to have a split I think
that's what it's formally called oh
where you split up what lifts you're
doing you know it seems like you're
doing a sort of body part bass split
which is can work for beginners I think
it's an excellent choice now if I
weren't a beginning when does the split
stop at what point
I think when you're when you're ready to
move on to something new when you're
saying okay I don't think this is giving
me the returns or when you learn new
information for example I think is a
good way to learn like when I realized
you know I'm not really hitting certain
muscles that I could that's when I you
know changed things up started switching
from a back barbell squat to a front
barbell squat wow you know you gotta you
got to look for these things well listen
Harry I'm not there quite yet but I do
appreciate the um the the check-in and
I'm gonna keep going okay
okay thanks for taking my call I just
have one more quick question and you can
answer it as briefly as you want to when
you I I listened to your interview with
Patrick Bet David I listened to the one
Sam Cedar had with him last week I think
you guys both did an excellent job
dismantling his lazy right-wing points
I'll put it
um but my question is how do you have
the like the confidence like I don't
want to say like media training-esque
feel to how you approach these guys but
what do you do mentally to just steady
yourself keep keep positive stay you
know on top of all your talking points
counter theirs what is the mentality I
really don't do any special prep I just
try to have my normal routine for the
day you know what I mean so like don't
because that what I find is like that
the Patrick Bet David thing is like in
the morning right if I shake up my
routine and like don't have the
breakfast I would normally have or
whatever if my routine is thrown off I
won't feel prepared so I think it's just
like maintaining my routine basically
and getting enough sleep
oh and he's gone oh where did it go all
right I hope I hope my answer was
satisfactory